[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kay
sölve richter und christian sievers
guten abend in ein gewitter und starker
regen lassen uns nicht los auch in der
kommenden woche nicht das wochenende
brachte den hochwasserregionen im westen
deutschlands neuen regen aber kein neues
unglück
anders in belgien da haben uns alle
gestern diese bilder aufgeschreckt die
stadt die nur rund 100 kilometer
westlich von aachen wo die feuerwehr
sagt es ist eine katastrophe
dominik löschmeister hat den überblick
autos einfach weggerissen häuser
überflutet so sieht es heute aus in der
südbelgischen stadt die nach den
heftigen regenfällen richtige sturzbäche
waren gestern abend die straßen hin
abgerauscht berichten augenzeugen
plötzlich passiert es hat wirklich
heftig geregnet
ich würde sagen 10 15 minuten später
kamen diese heftige flut von dort
herunter und wir konnten nichts tun
die schäden erheblich immerhin das
magische krisenzentrum meldet bisher
keine toten und verletzten
in den deutschen hochwassergebieten in
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
ist der große regen ausgeblieben die
menschen erleichtert wir hatten auch
schon wieder ein bisschen panik haben
wieder alles was schon putz war und so
weiter in sicherheit gebracht weil es
hieß ja so viel kommen aber es war gar
nichts in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler führt
sie durch den schutt um ihre patienten
zu versorgen christina schmid arbeitet
bei einem pflegedienst der caritas die
betreuung von pflegebedürftigen menschen
im katastrophengebiet eine
herausforderung extrem wichtig gerade
bei dementen patienten die brauchen die
ansprache
dass sie sicherheit haben dass die
soldaten auf den straßen zur hilfe da
sind und eben nicht etwas böses wollen
gute nachrichten kommen von der eu
kommission brüssel bietet deutschland
hilfe an
aus dem solidaritätsfonds können einen
teil der kosten für den einsatz und den
wiederaufbau übernommen werden und die
deutschen helfen weiter wo sie nur
können vor ort und bei der zdf
spendenaktion allein durch unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
sie alle sind mittlerweile fast 41
millionen euro zusammengekommen
und sie können weiter mithelfen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat die
bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das
stichwort zdf hochwasser mehr
informationen unter spenden zdf de und
im zdf text auf seite 8 190 ein
deutscher politiker ist gerade alles auf
einmal er ist ministerpräsident einer
katastrophenregion
er ist vorsitzender einer partei die in
den umfragen ganz vorn liegt und er will
neuer kanzler werden für dieses land
was er sagt und was er tut vor ort bei
den betroffenen und generell wenn es um
katastrophen vorsorge geht und den kampf
gegen die klimakrise
das steht natürlich unter ganz
besonderer beobachtung für armin laschet
ist das fluch und segen zugleich wie
mathis feldhoff zeigt wenn armin laschet
verspannt oder gar angespannt sein
sollte kann er es zumindest gut
verstecken sein erstes sommerinterview
nutzt der neue cdu chef urs ryffel
verteilen freundliche und weniger
freundliche helge braun bekommt den
ersten ab der kanzleramtsminister und
parteifreund hatte angedeutet dass
geimpfte demnächst deutlich mehr rechte
bekommen als ungeimpfte allerdings nicht
wenn es nach laschet geht ich halte
nichts von ihm pflicht
und halte auch nichts davon auf menschen
indirekt druck zu machen in einem
freiheitlichen staat gibt es
freiheitsrechte nicht nur für bestimmte
gruppen
es sind wochen der abwehr für den cdu
vorsitzenden corona klima steuern
laschet ist selten der schrittmacher er
muss er zügeln oft die eigenen leute bei
einem feld das besonders schwer
der csu-chef lässt sich per se nichts
sagen stattdessen fast täglich neue
gemeinheiten
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir in den
nächsten wochen dokumentieren dass es
nicht nur darum geht sich mit
schlafwagen ins kanzleramt zu fahren auf
langsame geschwindigkeit so wir müssen
jetzt zulegen
söder muss den namen laschet gar nichts
sagen er versteht auch so aber getroffen
wird er irgendwie nicht naja da du ja
recht schlaf angeht nicht wir müssen
schneller werden sie wissen wie er meint
gleich ein scholz also wir sind im tempo
auf dem wege und in der vorbereitung
dieses weglächeln ist auch eine stärke
die aber eine kehrseite hat das
unbeschwerte birgt gefahren
armin laschet hat eine gewisse
sorglosigkeit würde ich sagen in der
vorbereitung das was nach außen hin dann
immer so ein bisschen chaotisch anmutet
insofern kann man durchaus sagen sein
größter gegner an mancher stelle ist er
selbst und wie zum beweis liefert armin
laschet vor einer woche eine szene die
verstört vorne rede der bundespräsident
von leid und tod hinten kringelt sich
der kandidat vor lachen
was genau passiert ist will er auch
heute nicht sagen aber entschuldigt sich
erneut und es sollte nicht sein
und ich bin da auch es
seine vorgängerin ist auch an der
eigenen partei gescheitert das weiß
lastet und er versucht diesen fehler
nicht zu machen als die cdu-fraktionen
thüringen diese woche bei einem auf dem
misstrauensantrag mit einer stimmt
verweigerung reagiert wird ihr
vorgeworfen angst vor abweichlern zu
haben
laschet stellt sich heute vor seine
parteifreunde
insofern habe ich respekt wenn andere
sein wie man es mit einer nein stimme
ich finde zu sagen wir machen euch
spieleland hat der die parlamentarische
demokratie auch vorführen will das ist
die absicht von einer hätten dieses
spiel machen wir nicht mit
am ende geht laschet entspannt was im
interview geplante botschaft war das
spontane eingebung bleibt sein geheimnis
und ist vielleicht seine größte hürde
zur kanzler tauglichkeit
israel ist ein boomendes hightech
wunderland und ein ort an dem militär
und ict branche traditionell eng
verzahnt sind
mit dem versprechen von sicherheit lässt
sich gut politik machen und gute
geschäfte aktuell macht die nsu group
aus herzlia schlagzeilen sie hat pegasus
entwickelt ein schadprogramm das auf
handys zugreift ohne dass deren besitzer
irgend etwas merken und sie dann
ausspioniert
mit pegasus so der schwerwiegende
vorwurf eines weltweiten recherchen
netzwerks wurden in autoritär regierten
staaten auch regimekritiker und
journalisten gezielt überwacht und unter
druck gesetzt
die firma die gegründet worden sein soll
von ex mitgliedern einer hochgeheimen 2
bar überwachungseinheit und offenbar eng
mit israels geheimdienstapparat
verbunden ist bestreitet alle vorwürfe
die diskussion nicht nur in israel ist
damit nicht vom tisch michael bewerunge
berichtet aus tel aviv
diese woche fand in israel die cyber
week statt eine fachkonferenz zum thema
cybersicherheit mit experten aus aller
welt
wie passend könnte man meinen dass kurz
zuvor der nsu skandal geplatzt war
dass die aps software der israelischen
firma weltweit offenbar auch illegal
gegen politiker journalisten und
menschenrechte eingesetzt wurde ist hier
offiziell kein thema auch auf nachfrage
kaum antworten ein fachbeamter aus dem
büro des premierministers weist jede
verantwortung zurück
das mag solche firmen geben viele
solcher firmen in vielen ländern der
welt aber wir haben mit denen nichts zu
tun das ist eine völlig andere
zuständigkeit vielleicht verteidigung
vielleicht hat der verteidigungsminister
antworten aber auch im zuständigen
verteidigungsministerium im allgemeinen
mehr für seine angriffs hardware bekannt
als für angriffs software ist man sich
keiner schuld bewusst auf anfrage des
zdf zu den cyber exportrichtlinien heißt
es der staat israel bewilligt den export
von cyber produkten ausschließlich für
regierungsinstitutionen für den
gesetzeskonformen einsatz und nur zum
zwecke der verhütung und aufklärung von
verbrechen und der terrorismusbekämpfung
das ist beim verkauf der
spionagesoftware pegasus offiziell egal
zuging bezweifeln auch menschenrechtler
nicht doch der verdacht dass
staatsmänner wie der französische
präsident ausgespäht wurden oder die
software gar half den saudi cascioli zu
ermorden zeige die
missbrauchsmöglichkeiten der
menschenrechtsanwalt teilmarkt wirft
israels regierung vor sie wolle sich aus
der verantwortung stehlen mehrfach hat
er gegen den export der nsu software
geklagt ohne erfolg
das problem ist dass sich fragt welche
art von regierung die ns software
bekommt und wie diese regierungen
kriminalität und terrorismus definieren
in staaten wie saudi arabien wo anders
an und marokko ist es bereits ein
verbrechen mitglied der opposition zu
sein oder unabhängiger journalist
noch schlimmer das ganze folge
politischem kalkül der verkauf von
software sei unauffälliger als der
verkauf von waffen
jahrelang habe vor allem die regierung
netanjahu so diplomatie betrieben
da der see gibt es parallele zeitabläufe
wanders eines o system mit mars lich
gegen menschenrechtsaktivisten und
journalisten eingesetzt wurde und dem
besuch von netanjahu in diesen ländern
so ging das jahrzehnte statt der knesset
sollen nun das verteidigungsministerium
und der sicherheitsrat die vorgänge
untersuchen das cyber system
kontrolliert sich lieber selbst
edward snowden sagt dass es ein
geschäftszweig ein industriezweig der
eigentlich gar nicht existieren sollte
der eben alles andere als schutz
verkaufe und er benutzt das bild das sie
keine impfung verkaufen sondern eben
immer nur neue gefährliche viren
reporter ohne grenzen dokumentiert
weltweit verstöße gegen die
pressefreiheit schlägt alarm wenn
journalisten in gefahr sind christian
mir ist der deutsche geschäftsführer
herr mir guten abend guten abend
wir haben es gerade gesehen und dazu
kommt der bericht der israelischen
zeitung haaretz sie spricht von israels
regierung als patron der cyber industrie
wenn sie das alles so sehen ist dass
wirtschaftsförderung der ganz besonderen
art ja offenbar ist das unternehmen
indes so grubert für den export von
pegasus verantwortlich ist auch ein
instrument der israelischen außen und
wirtschaftspolitik das haben wir durch
die recherchen erfahren ist aber für uns
letztlich auch keine neue erkenntnis bei
reporter ohne grenzen
jetzt sind die vorwürfe die da kommen ja
massiv und es ist wenn das stimmt eine
ganz neue perfide art des umgangs mit
journalistinnen und journalisten mit
regime-gegnern können sie mal
beschreiben was konkret das so
gefährlich macht dem ein ganz konkret
diese technik die erlaubte es ja ein
handy zu verwandeln um ein mikro
anzumachen eine wanze daraus zu schalten
erlaubtes komplettes signal whatsapp
kommunikation mitzuschneiden aber das
entscheidende für journalisten
journalisten ist es gefährlich weil
journalisten ein versprechen geben und
das ist vertraulichkeit sie versprechen
menschen die sich ihnen mit
korruptionsfällen an vertrauen dass das
unter ihnen bleibt diese software
verhindert ist dass journalisten dieses
versprechen einhalten können und auch ja
unter druck gesetzt werden mit
gewonnenen informationen ganz
offensichtlich oder
ja das wissen wir bei reporter ohne
grenzen aus unserer eigenen arbeit wir
leisten weltweit nothilfe für verfolgte
journalisten und wir wissen dass oben
gefährt die hälfte aller journalisten
journalisten denen wir helfen aus
notlagen dass diese gefoltert wurden
dass diese verhaftet wurden
dass sie das land verlassen mussten in
der folge von digitaler überwachung auch
mit solchen tools und deswegen sehen wir
wie gravierend das ist und es ist ein
globaler markt in dem vor allen dingen
ja israel die blende mehrere länder
europäischen union die usa aktiv sind
jetzt haben wir uns daran gewöhnt bei
waffen wie panzer angeboten genau
hinzuschauen so eine software ist in
gewisser weise ja auch eine waffe ist
das denn allen weltweit genügend klar
es liegen seit einigen jahren ganz
konkrete vorschläge auf dem tisch aber
es fehlt der politische wille es gibt
seit 2013 im rahmen des
wassermanagements zum zu konventionellen
waffen eine regulierungs regime aber da
ist israel nicht mitglied und drei
viertel drei viertel der weltweiten
exporte fallen aus israel auf
europäische länder und in die usa und im
rahmen dieser pegasus software wissen
wir auch dass offenbar bulgarien und
zypern also zwei eu-länder
exportlizenzen vergeben haben müssen
dh dass sie es nicht nur ein
israelisches problem das ist potenziell
auch ein europäisches problem
jetzt ist das alles sehr geheim es ist
alles dementiert es ist gleichzeitig
sehr sehr viel geld im spiel
haben sie hoffnung dass sich das
tatsächlich ändern wird und nicht immer
schlimmer wird wenn ich keine hoffnung
hätte dann würde ich nicht hier setzen
sitzen und mich nicht einsetzen seit
vielen jahren für eine bessere
regulierung denn es gibt konkrete
vorschläge für eine regulierung des
exports solcher technik und deswegen
fordern wir ein sofortiges moratorium
dieses export und des verkaufs und des
einsatzes von allen staaten und dass
endlich die staaten dieser welt die das
blockieren
endlich auch die einer besseren gut für
eine bessere regulierung eintreten und
es gibt da kommt
räte vorschläge um so etwas auf
internationaler ebene völkerrechtlich
besser zu machen
auf un ebene könnte man das machen man
muss es nur umsetzen und ich hoffe dass
die enthüllungen dieser woche den
politischen willen endlich befördern
sagt christel meyer der geschäftsführer
von reporter ohne grenzen hat mir
herzlichen dank danke auch und das
interview haben wir vorhin aufgezeichnet
nochmal adwords snowden er sagt wenn wir
das nicht stoppen dann wird es nicht bei
50.000 betroffenen bleiben es werden 50
millionen werden die
nachrichtenübersicht an diesem sonntag
hat jetzt keine selber zwei monate vor
der bundestagswahl steigt die sorge vor
hacker attacken und falschinformationen
allein im it-bereich jemand von etlichen
risiken aus dass sagte bundeswahlleiter
georg thiel der welt am sonntag man habe
aber für alle szenarien gegenmaßnahmen
geplant wegen der korona pandemie geht
hier von einem deutlich höheren anteil
an briefwählern aus als bei früheren
bundestagswahlen bei einem busunglück
sind in kroatien mindestens zehn
menschen ums leben gekommen 45 insassen
wurden verletzt
der reisebus war auf dem weg von
frankfurt am main nach pristina als er
von der straße abkam
offenbar war der fahrer eingeschlafen
bei den toten soll es sich um kosovaren
handeln die in deutschland arbeiten und
in ihrer heimat urlaub machen wollten
außerdem starb ein zweiter fahrer er war
ein prägendes gesicht des ddr fernsehens
und stand auch im hohen alter noch auf
der bühne
nun ist der schauspieler herbert köfer
gestorben 1952 war las der gebürtige
berliner die ersten nachrichten in der
aktuellen kamera in die herzen seiner
zuschauer spielte er sich vor allem in
seiner paraderolle als opa paul schmidt
in der ddr serie rentner haben niemals
zeit herbert köfer wurde 100 jahre alt
durch heftigen monsunregen sind in
westindien mehr als 100 menschen ums
leben gekommen
und die zahl der toten wird wohl noch
steigen denn zahlreiche einwohner werden
noch vermisst
die meisten im bundesstaat maharashtra
wo ein gewaltiger erdrutsch ein dorf
unter sich begraben hat
die retter müssen sich dort durch meter
hohen schlamm kämpfen
eine entwarnung ist nicht in sicht es
soll noch tagelang weiter regnen
bayreuth der grüne hügel das ist
normalerweise ein sommer leichtes
feriencamp für wagner-fans sieht auch
immer noch so aus einfach weil man all
die auflagen und einschränkungen nicht
auf den ersten blick entdeckt bayreuth
20 21 ist eine strikte 3g veranstaltung
geimpft genesen getestet mit eigenen
testzentrum hinterm ehrwürdigen
festspielhaus aber und darauf kommt es
am ende an der schall kehrt zurück in
den raum in dem er sich seit 145 jahren
faszinierender verteilt als anderswo und
am dirigentenpult steht seit 145 jahren
zum ersten mal eine frau barbara lueg
nimmt uns mit so schaut oksana linie aus
wenn sie sichtbar dirigiert berauscht
fiebrig versunken
im weltberühmten bayreuther
orchestergraben mit seinem schall deckel
aber ist sie unsichtbar fürs publikum
sie würden sie nur aus der tiefe dieses
mythischen abgrund
die erste frau am dirigentenpult in der
geschichte der festspiele ein
historischer moment aber sieht sie das
auch so eigenen überhaupt nicht weil die
aufgaben sind dieselbe die partitur oder
die aufgaben die wagner für uns gestellt
hat werden dadurch nicht leichter oder
schwerer oksana lunis stammt aus der
ukraine ihre kindheit ist karg aber
gefüllt mit musik sie studiert und
kämpft sich vor
zu unserem interview kommt sie mit
unzähligen notizen in ihrer dicken
premieren party tour wie lange sie die
noten studiert hat über ein jahr
natürlich aber grundsätzlich bereit
nämlich schon drei jahre vor drei jahre
vorbereitung für diesen auftritt und so
klingt das dann premiere fliegender
holländer oxana dirigiert unten im
graben
[Musik]
für diese premiere sporteln richard
wagner akribisch nach hinein in seine
welt denn die regieren bedeutet eben
nicht nur das klang gefühl des
komponisten zu empfinden sondern auch
sein leben persönliche dramen
zeitgeschichte
es geht um was es geht um musikalische
dramaturgie
es geht um transparenz es gibt es geht
um klanggestaltung bilder entfalten ja
das ganze diese ganze drama zum leben zu
bringen
vieles in bayreuth ist anders in diesem
jahr die zentrale auf ohne roten teppich
neben an die food trucks und strengster
hygiene regeln aber die kanzlerin ist
verlässlich da und auch er ist hier
christian thielemann stardirigent
vertraut mit den tücken der bayreuther
akustik blickt er heute auf das debüt
der kollegin
ich finde es ein richtiges zeichen und
die bleiben die für euch sind sollen
zeigen dass es können und ich finde es
auch ganz gut dass es hier jetzt
passiert dass sie es allen beweisen will
und alles dafür gibt wird der abend in
bayreuth heute sicher zeigen in die
geschichte geht sie als erster dirigent
in jetzt schon ein
und jetzt das was kommen wird in der
nächsten woche der heute journal
ausblick von kameras auf java
[Musik]
die flutkatastrophe in deutschland wird
am montag den innenausschuss des
bundestages beschäftigen
in einer sondersitzung soll es dabei
auch um die abläufe der wahn und
alarmierungs verfahren gehen
bundesinnenminister seehofer hat sein
kommen zugesagt
der sturm auf das kapitol jetzt sollen
die hintergründe aufgeklärt werden am
dienstag werden in einem
untersuchungsausschuss des
repräsentantenhauses sicherheitskräfte
dazu angehört
beim sturm auf das herz der us
demokratie waren im januar fünf menschen
ums leben gekommen mehr als 80 millionen
menschen sind weltweit auf der flucht
das bis heute wichtigste dokument für
den flüchtlingsschutz die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention wieder mittwoch 70
jahre alt sie legt fest wer ein
flüchtling ist welchen schutz und welche
rechte er genießt aber auch welche
pflichten er hat ebenfalls am mittwoch
wird der bundesgerichtshof erstmals ein
höchstrichterliches urteil zu den comics
deals sprechen
jahrelang hatten dabei investoren den
start um milliarden geprellt 2020 waren
zwei börsenhändler zu bewährungsstrafen
verurteilt worden und hatten revision
eingelegt
und zum ausblick gehört natürlich auch
der blick aufs wetter morgen gibt es vor
allem im norden und südwesten schauer
und teils kräftige gewitter wobei im
norden die unwettergefahr am größten ist
sonst wechseln sich sonne und wolken ab
bei 22 bis 28 grad
die schauer und gewitter bleiben uns
auch in den tagen danach erhalten bei
höchstwerten zwischen 21 und 30 grad
und mit diesen aussichten sagen wir
beide danke für das interesse ab morgen
sind hier bettina schausten und gundula
gause für sie da
[Musik]